the long-awaited Durham report four
years later has finally been released
special counsel John Durham found that
the Department of Justice and the FBI
quote failed to uphold their mission and
never should have launched the Trump
Russia investigation David spunt is
standing by to break this down and then
we'll dig into it here hi David hi
Martha hi everyone literally four years
actually four years in two days May 13
2019 that is when John Durham then U.S
attorney in Connecticut was tapped to
look at the origins of the Trump Russia
probe he wrote today in his 306-page
report that the findings are sobering
there's one big theme here that the
Hillary Clinton campaign was treated
much differently than the Donald Trump
campaign I want to pull out one
important quote here again this is one
of many he wrote We conclude that the
department and the FBI failed to uphold
their important mission of strict
Fidelity to the law Inc connection with
certain events and activities described
in this report end quote first we have
to go back to the years
2016-2017. the primary focus of this
report now the overarching theme as I
say Durham says the FBI rushed an
investigation called Crossfire hurricane
without the proper basis Crossfire
hurricane is the umbrella name for the
investigation into alleged connections
between the Trump campaign and Russia
now Durham took two cases to trial over
the past four years he lost them both
the first Michael Sussman a cyber lawyer
with ties to the Clinton campaign the
other Igor danchenko a Russian
intelligence operative who helped craft
that Infamous steel dossier full of
salacious allegations about then
candidate Donald Trump Kevin kleinsmith
was a former FBI attorney he actually
pleaded guilty to altering a document
used to surveil a trump campaign Aid now
the FBI was then under the leadership of
Jim Comey it's changed many times since
then several layers of leadership the
FBI putting out a statement today had
those reforms has been in place since
2016 the missteps identified in the
report could have been prevented this
report reinforces the importance of
ensuring the FBI continues to do its
work with the rigor objectivity and
professionalism the American people
deserve and rightly expect now President
Biden's attorney general mayor Garland
received Martha this Durham report on
Friday looked at it over the weekend
gave it today to Congress and
transmitted it to the public without
making any changes so it's the way
Durham wants it to be to the public
Martha all right David spunt thank you
very much well uh this has been as David
said four years and millions of dollars
in the making and in just the first few
pages you get a very strong sense of
what they determined here which is what
we've been talking about here for years
and that is that this whole Crossfire
hurricane investigation was launched on
the thinnest thread from an Australian
informant they ignored what their own
Russian analysts were telling them at
the same time they had similar inquiries
into the Hillary Clinton Campaign which
they put on a which they just shelved
and ignored completely it is so clear
reading through this document that
Andrew McCabe and Peter strzok and James
Comey who was at the top of the FBI had
a plan that they executed regardless of
what the facts were and it falls I think
quite cleanly into a trump derangement
that had its grip on the FBI in the wake
of the 2016 election there is so much
contradictory Behavior here from the way
that Trump was treated and the way that
the Clinton campaign was treated this is
an enormous embarrassment I said earlier
Janine that this that sure are so many
media organizations who have so much egg
on their face today and I was looking
while this news was breaking at the
lower thirds on the other channels FBI
says there was no foundation for this
investigation and I think my mind is
just replaying Jim Brennan James Clapper
awaiting for all of these indictments it
is appalling what was thrust upon the
American people with this story when you
dig into how little they built all of
this on Janine well they you know it's
not just the legal piece of it where
they say that the FBI and the doj fail
to uphold their mission uh with to
strict Fidelity to the law they split
this country apart they had families not
talking to each other parties more and
more divided and here we are seven years
later still divided and yet everything
that we said is true everything that we
accuse them of was true Jim Comey had no
right to come out and say no reasonable
prosecutor would try Hillary and this
guy Kevin kleinsmith where are the
defendants Klein Smith actually altered
the basis for a warrant he's still
practicing law the Durham lost two cases
that danchenko and Sussman so to me I
have to tell you I am disgusted it's all
words and I am more disgusted that the
FBI comes out and says had those reforms
been in place none of this would ever
have happened that's baloney and I'll
tell you why it's baloney because we had
people protesting in Supreme Court
Justices home trying to get them to
change a bending decision and a federal
statute there was no arrest because we
had the doj saying that parents are
domestic terrorists we have an out of
control intelligence agency 51
intelligence agents lying about Russian
disinformation we've got doj FBI they're
not afraid of anything anymore Martha
because none of them are having their
feet held to the fire and as the New
York Times or the Washington Post going
to return the pulitzers absolutely
absolutely
um Jesse you know you you look at this
case and you think I think about the day
that James Comey was fired and the
horrified reactions
um from other networks right and I'm
thinking well if he had I mean he had
there was every reason to fire him if he
was still in place he should be fired
today based on his absolute negligence
and not only negligence manipulation of
the truth
well Democrats win elections and we get
a report four years old that told us
everything we already knew
we already knew that they framed Donald
Trump for treason we knew the fact that
Hillary created the Russia collusion
hoax we knew Barack Obama was briefed on
crooked scam to link them to Russia and
we knew that they fabricated evidence to
spy on the Trump campaign Obama
administration officials spied on the
Trump campaign illegally based on a hoax
that crooked cooked up
and then they cleaned it all up with the
Mueller investigation which was a fake
investigation designed to tee up an
impeachment that didn't work here's what
we didn't know we didn't know this we
didn't know that the FBI shut down
investigations into the Clinton
Foundation we didn't know that they shut
down investigations into illegal foreign
contributions that's right to the
Clinton campaign also new details that
Durham brings out Comey was the one who
personally pushed for the spine he
pushed hard for the fisa and now we're
not we're finding out that the FBI
told their officials don't write
anything down don't put anything in
writing because they knew this was nasty
also it looks like the P tape came from
the Democrats it never even came from
the Russians it never even came from the
Ritz Carlton it came from that Dolan cat
that created the pite also a bunch of
agents at the FBI in the Department of
Justice refused to cooperate with John
Durham so we still don't even really
know the full truth and
told you he wasn't going to deliver yeah
um Jessica where do the American people
go to get two years of the presidency
that they voted for back because the
president was Under This Cloud non-stop
during his presidency and maybe we
should get a redo who needs to apologize
we can't survive the redo of that and
frankly Donald Trump got some of his
best moments out of the quote Russia did
the American people he fed off of it oh
come on
no I mean really I mean who benefited
you're saying someone actually benefited
from this Trump who is a showman
benefited by being a victim of this and
that's why he continues to proliferate
the image that he is a victim he did it
last week okay
here's the thing with the John Durham
investigation
if all of what Jesse just said is true
why are there no new charges why does
someone put out a 306 page report I
think that's what it was and everyone
then just goes home goes about their
business Inside Job Jessica you can't
everything Maybe
they're just losers right maybe there
isn't truth to what you've been arguing
all along here
because you
so two things about the report the
report says that there's truth and that
the point of this was to find whether
any person or entity violated the law
John Durham could say all this but he
doesn't find any legal law breaking
otherwise he would bring new charges he
tried three times he has one low level
conviction and two acquittals basically
came up with bup kiss after four years
okay for the FBI to manipulate what the
American people think based on lies it's
it is absolutely not okay I think that
they should have told the Trump campaign
if there were people that were trying to
influence it yeah but the only person
who actually lost out by the FBI was
Hillary Clinton when Jim Comey got up
there 11 days before the election and
said that they had a second
investigation opened into her emails and
didn't know anything
that just came out that they um want to
make sure that we mentioned here uh
former president Trump this is his first
statement about this he says I and much
more importantly than American public
have been victims of this long-running
and treasonous charade started by the
Democrat that's started by Comey there
must be a heavy price to pay for putting
our country through this there's no
price and that's the response because
when you get too high up nobody pays
I just can't wait till I am falsely
accused of something I'm gonna have so
much fun because I hear it's great for
your career like in the moment someone
accuses me of something Jessica I'm
gonna run with it because you know
accuse me now with something please I'm
thinking something I'm sure you are look
it was a point I made I don't know years
ago that if the if you have people
saying that the country will not survive
Trump then your moral duty is to cheat
right and you should cheat it like if
somebody is telling everybody that this
person is a modern day Hitler it is your
duty to do whatever is possible to stop
him in fact if you actually play by the
rules you're a traitor right so the they
created a devil that was so big and so
vast and made all actions permissible
and it made every institution as as the
judge was saying subject to suspicion
right so you can bury stories you can
create hoaxes you can fund smears it
could go anywhere because this person
must be stopped it's him an existential
threat and so what happens is now we're
left
and none of it's true and so we had a
half a decade hoax that infected and
undermined every institution because we
were made to believe this person is evil
and then people make fun of people who
are skeptical about an election
why shouldn't they be skeptical about an
election when the doj and the FBI and
the in the mainstream media and the tech
companies in the Chamber of Commerce are
all in on the same thing uh why
shouldn't the election be called into
question right shouldn't a hero try to
fix the election right shouldn't a hero
do that if you're up against Hitler
that's where we ended up and you can't
go and condemn people for so-called
conspiracy theories when you were going
around telling everybody this guy was
worse than Hitler well and if you listen
to Jessica's argument and you're going
to be hearing this all day on the other
networks is that because the justice
department didn't indict the justice
department that means everything was
fine because they got away with it no it
means that if you have all these people
who during the Mueller investigation
from Trump's team like his campaign
manager like Rick gave Michael Flynn
Roger Stone Etc they were able to find
real things to convict them of and you
can't find them on the clintons
is that this justice system is not blind
uh it had a lot of things on both sides
chose not to pursue those chose to
pursue the others and that is a choice
that should never be made by outstanding
individuals
Democrats weaponized the justice system
and America has no faith we're happy
because you got away with it I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now